DHHS is no longer ignoring the law we
are enforcing the laws as they exist on
the books as long as illegal entry
remains a criminal offense DHS will not
look the other way
DHS will faithfully execute the laws
enacted by Congress as we are sworn to
do as I said earlier today surely it is
the beginning of the unraveling of
democracy when the body who makes the
laws instead of changing them tells the
enforcement body not to enforce the law
I ask Congress to ask this week so that
we can secure our borders and uphold our
humanitarian ideas these two missions
should not be pitted against each other
if we close the loopholes we can
accomplish both the pictures are
horrible the emotions are high the
criticism is all over the place and the
blame game has begun in earnest we can
do this very quickly if the Democrats
come to the table everybody wants to do
it we want to do it more than they do
they will try to make us choose between
these children and dreamers or
Democratic friends every time they've
had a chance to vote for a solution that
they voted against it and so I hope they
change their change their approach put
it on the floor and let the people's
house vote and yet they slumber still
with that let's bring in our panel
former CIA analyst nationally syndicated
radio host buck Sexton marl is a
national political correspondent Public
Radio a Molly Hemingway senior editor at
The Federalist Mara this seems like it's
all coming to a head here yes and this
has been confusing because this was a
policy that was meant as a deterrent and
described as a deterrent by Jeff
Sessions and others don't bring your
kids here because you're gonna get
separated from them if you cross
illegally but it turns out that I think
President Trump wants credit for being
tough on immigration today he says that
we don't want our country to turn into a
migrant camp or a holding pen for
refugees but he doesn't want to take
responsibility for the unpopular part of
the policy which
is the separation of kids from their
mothers so he's blaming the Democrats
mom you know it it's been talked of as a
deterrent in part because of what's
happened as people have learned what
previous administrations did in handling
this law so you saw in previous
administrations that when people crossed
the border illegally and then claimed
after they were caught that they were
asylum seekers they would just sort of
be let go and asked to report back at a
later date
a lot of people figured out this was a
very good way to get into the country
that you would be able to just pass
through if you brought children that
increased the number of children who are
used as you were crossing the border and
so you started to see the number of
cases of people crossing this way just
skyrocket so they need to kind of make a
deterrent out of this since people have
figured out this is a good way to cross
there is a moral cost to not following
the nation's laws there's a moral cost
to separating children from their
families and it is important that
Democrats and Republicans come together
to respect the laws of the land and they
need to keep families together
here's secretary Neilson today on those
fraudulent claims going up the last five
months we have a 314 percent increase in
adults and children arriving at the
border fraudulently claiming to be a
family unit this is obviously of concern
and separation can occur when the parent
is charged with human smuggling under
those circumstances we would detain the
parent in an appropriate secure
detention facility separate from the
child a buck no matter how you explain
it whether you say they're gonna seek
asylum they choose to separate whether
the percentages is 314 percent the
images and the emotion around this issue
or a political dynamite that's why the
Trump I think understands this has to be
handled you can't have mothers being
separated from incredibly young children
I do think that there'll be a good faith
effort to solve that part of it but
there is a legacy of lawlessness here
and at some point I think it becomes all
too apparent that not just the Obama
administration but the current Democrat
Party would prefer a situation where
essentially anybody who can get into the
country can stay at some point they have
to be willing to answer the question
which illegal aliens are no longer
allowed to stay in the country they
created this loophole really a massive
front door entryway to the United States
by bringing a child with you then all of
a sudden it became quite easy to stay in
the country
so you want to fix the issue of
separating parents from children while
being processed but you also do have to
enforce the law about people who are
coming here illegally and by the way in
many cases claiming asylum in bad faith
they are saying what they've been Trevor
what they've been told to say the word
is out secretary Neilson has been
addressing that the young people who are
coming or unaccompanied they're in
jeopardy
there are many thousands of
unaccompanied minors who have showed up
at the border without anybody so that's
dangerous for them too the incentive
that was put in place with the Obama
ministration has to stop this has to end
the prospects of this forcing some kind
of bipartisan solution I mean does it
did it change because last week the
prospect of immigration law getting into
law a bill getting into law was pretty
bad look bad there have been so many
attempts over the past year one was this
deal will give you full funding for the
wall if you legalize the dreamers now
it's something akin to that but also we
want to do something about separating
kids from their families
Donald Trump has asked for a 44 percent
decrease in legal immigration which the
Democrats have booked out I think that
if you got it down to a pretty skinny
bill wall dreamers the kids and family
policies maybe you could get something
but I don't know if that's where
Congress has had the dreaded skinny bill
we've heard that so many times before
Molly Ted Cruz has just introduced
legislation that would deal with this
the big issue in play is that you can't
detain children for more than 20 days it
takes so long to deal with adjudicating
these illegal border crossings that then
claim asylum that it ends up in family
separation his bill would require that
you adjudicate this within two weeks and
if you fail to pass the test you're
deported as a family and otherwise you
can be reunited at that point we should
say that secretary Nielson made a point
to say if you go to a port of entry that
you can claim asylum and stay together
as a family if there's room and then if
they think you're a real family I think
they can check you out as a real family
here is a blast from the past if you
will Hillary Clinton on this issue
the president's attempt today to stoke
fear of immigrants not only in our
country but around the world by claiming
that migrants in Germany are causing
crime
in fact crime in Germany is at its
lowest level since 1992
nor are these policies rooted in
religion in fact those who selectively
use the Bible to justify this cruelty
are ignoring a central tenet of
Christianity spent a long time buck on
this issue as you can imagine touching
all elements of it today very dishonest
in terms of what mrs. Clinton is
presenting there as what's happening in
Germany what happened since 1992 in
terms of crime doesn't really matter
what matters is what has happened in
Germany since the massive migrant wave
and there it's quite clear that you have
had about a ten percent increase in
violent crime in homicides and rates the
kind of crimes that people really care
about and notice and in a country like
Germany where you already have a low
number once those start to hit the
airwaves and by the way I think there's
there is a hesitation some of these
European countries to speak openly about
these crimes we see it in Sweden we see
in Germany the press doesn't want to
deal with it
she's just wrong on the facts or rather
she's misconstruing the reality what's
happened there by picking cherry picking
what's happened in 1992 they do have
some very serious problems in Germany
with the migrant wave that has serious
problems in other parts of Europe
as well and I think mrs. Clinton knows
that but right now it's better to play
to the emotions of something when you
have Hillary Clinton and Laura Bush on
the same side on the same issue does it
create some bigger force well I think
Laura Bush was a really extraordinary
entry into this debate she doesn't ever
ever comment on things like this and she
did you know the other aspect of that
tweet he went after Angela Merkel I've
never seen a US president do this before
he was suggesting that her hold on power
was teetering on the brink because of
this it almost as if he was echoing his
ambassador to Germany who said that he
wanted to encourage conservative parties
to take over in these countries I mean
that is the kind of meddling that I
don't think he would like if a foreign
leader did in our poll that's what mine
well an Angela Merkel is having some
political trouble in part because of how
she evolution together part because of
how she's handled this emigrate but he
was encouraging that okay well leave it
there